hi I'm Victoria Braun co-founder of big
Singh Kham
the way we live and work is changing at
a faster pace than ever before since Big
Think launched in 2008 our mission has
always been to help our audience get
smarter faster before you idea-driven
video interviews with thousands of
global thought leaders from dr. michio
kaku
to henry rollins to salman rushdie and
many many more you've helped us become
one of YouTube's most popular education
channels with a really vibrant community
of users and now corresponding to your
feedback we've created big think mentor
to bring you the world-class ideas of
our experts transferred into actionable
tools to help you lead more productive
happier and healthier lives up to 40% of
skinny people actually may be what we
call skinny fat people they look thin
but they're metabolically obese people
will work much harder not to lose
something than they will to gain
something and that's not depressing it's
very useful you can leverage that so
basically what research suggests is that
focusing on that focusing on the future
focusing on your goals makes people
happy
you know striving actually makes people
much happier than actually then even
achieving I assert that if you were
depressed after learning and being
exposed to the cosmic perspective you
started your day with an unjustifiably
large
well update our programming each month
to respond to your changing needs
watch our expert video and then
reinforce your learning with a guided
thought experiment or life experiment
provided in the comment section below
report back on your results engage in
community debate and make
recommendations for new experts and
areas of study join us today and become
a founding member of big think mentor
you